hey 42 here hi tree on the corner of
Punt Road and Alexander Avenue and that
little chute that goes up the side how
are you how old are you
I've always wondered about you ever
since by slightly strange driving
instructor who always felt like cat food
and peppermints told me you were his
favorite trait I hope they don't knock
you down this was an email written to a
tree in Melbourne Australia yes a tree
to combat the steady decline of trees in
Melbourne following a 13 year drought
the city devised a genius plan called
the urban forest strategy whilst their
genius plan to invest in better
irrigation system to keep the city's
trees water than the intense Ozzy heat
no that's what they instead gave each
and every tree in Melbourne an email
address that's 77,000 trees the idea is
that Melbourne residents could report
tree vandalism and broken branches or
other issues that could threaten the
tree's well-being to the City Council by
directly emailing the tree itself sounds
great but it went very wrong in the most
amazing way possible people started to
write love letters to their favorite
trees since the scheme went live
Melbourne City Council have received
thousands of love letters via email from
all over the world addressed to the
newly famous trees of Melbourne if you
see a Melburnian tree you like yourself
on Google Street View you can go to the
project's website and find its email
address as I can imagine happened when a
brush box tree received a following
email from a mysterious gentleman in
Russia hello dear tree I read about this
wonderful project and supposed to write
you from another side of Earth Russia I
hope you have a good care and don't sick
one day we will meet maybe ov Vladimir I
never knew you as such a lover of nature
also an elm tree received this email
from a fellow 15,000 kilometers away in
jolly old England is not for me honest
dear elm I was delighted to find you
alive and flourishing because a lot of
your family used to live in the UK but
they all caught a terrible infection and
died
do be very careful and if you notice any
unfamiliar insects email and
agriculturalists at once I miss your
characteristic silhouettes and
beautifully shaped branches used to be
one of the glories of the English
landscape more than I can say male born
must be a beautiful City sincere God
wishes
D the trees have received every kind of
email from quick greetings love letters
and poems questions about current events
and politics and even existential
dilemmas one gentleman called Troy was
so concerned about the Greek debt crisis
that he had a full-on political debate
with a local red cedar tree and yes the
tree actually emailed back as they often
do Troy opened with hi tree are you
worried about being affected by the
Greek debt crisis should Greece be
allowed to stay in the European Union
regards Troy to which the tree replied
hi Troy I seem to remember the Greek ask
you to the ground one time are you still
angry at them Greece is not out of the
woods yet
but maybe out of the EU some say that
they should be allowed to devalue their
currency in order to recover their
economy but the EU will not allow them
to do that some say that is partly the
austerity program which has made it this
bad they say austerity was a disaster
for Russia after the breakup of the
Soviet Union and for the recovery of
Asia from the GFC I don't know but then
I'm only a tree regards Western redcedar
overall the project has been a huge
success and despite the unintended
consequences being able to email trees
has vastly increased the citizens of
Melbourne's interest in looking after
and increasing the amount of trees in
Melbourne having canopy cover from
thousands of trees decreases the average
temperature of the entire city by four
degrees Celsius in the summer which is
needed as it's bloody Australia
I just hope residents don't become too
attached to their local trees as I fear
for what they might do to them one
golden elm tree already has a stalker
whose latest email read dear one zero
three seven one four eight you deserve
to be known by much more than Justin
I love you always and forever yeah this
whole thing will start to get really
weird thanks for watching there are
estimated to be around 100 so-called
uncontacted tribes left in the world
people who have had little to no outside
contact one such tribe lives on the
remote North Sentinel island in the Bay
of Bengal think back to the last time
you had an apple when do you think it
was picked a couple of days ago a couple
of weeks ago perhaps try a year